I think the biggest vulnerability you've
got is you actually value somebody's
opinion more than you value your own but
the reason I've been able to always do
my thing is when I was 24 and people
were like oh you work at your dad's
liquor store like I heard that it's like
a chip on my shoulder you know I loved
it
I was like cool keep sleeping on me you
know like I'm glad you're on Wall Street
making a hundred thousand buying BMWs
and dumb jewelry I'll see you in 30
years you understand like to me the way
you win is you realize you can't hear
nobody not your parents I mean listen
you got to listen to coach and all that
I get it but at the end of the day my
guy yourself you got to get real real
quiet up here I can't hear anything you
go look at my Instagram right now my
first post I'll post something first
hundred replies in one second you're
Jesus
you walk up water you're the best you're
the old-time can't hear him the next
hundred you're a piece of your foolish
you're a snake oil salesman can't hear
him I'm in my own mind doing my own
thing and that comes with self-esteem
everybody's trying to keep up with the
Joneses I'm not worried about you being
in the Hamptons on a blow-up Swan I'm
not worried about you renting out cash
from the bank and putting it to your ear
I'm not worrying you jumped a fence and
took a photo in front of a private plane
what do you think these people are doing
they're posing patients long game you
know what's amazing about being an
entrepreneur we get to play forever
right I'm gonna be working when I'm 96
trying to find my next hustle
the foundational base of empowerment of
entrepreneurship of any kind of
engagement the foundational base of my
success of my well-being
my wholeness my everything is knowing
who I am and where I come from in my
living room right now is a painting that
I've owned now for thirty years you can
google it it's called to the highest
bidder and it's at the center of my
house and it's at the center of my house
because it actually is symbolic of the
foundation of not the house but the
foundation for my life the painting is
by Harry Rosalind who was a genre
painter in the early 20th 19th century
and the painting is over 6 feet tall and
it shows a slave woman on the auction
block holding her daughter's hand and I
cannot come in the door my front door or
I cannot leave without passing that
painting I am reminded of where I come
from every day of my life and I am
reminded because I never want to forget
it and in my library I have a framed
list of enslaved African American people
who were held in bondage on various
plantations listed in the ledgers
alongside the cows and the horses and
the buggies and the other property and I
passed this list every day and often I
stopped in front of it and just speak
their names
out loud and their ages Jonah's eleven
years old
five hundred dollars Sarah forty-one
years old nine hundred dollars Elizabeth
fifty seven eight hundred dollars and I
forced myself to consider the absurdity
and the obscenity of prices being
affixed to each one should they be
placed up for sale and I sometimes just
pause before them with a prayer
particularly before I have to make a big
decision about one of my companies or
whether I move forward or whether I stay
still it reminds me speaking those names
out loud not only of where I've come
from how far I have to go because of
them and it reminds me that I am never
alone it reminds me of what I've come
through to get through if you had to
think of one word that's most important
to you or that sums you up or that would
be like a little beacon if you liked
this video and want more check out the
one I made on how to be a master of
self-discipline the link is right there
next to me I think you'll enjoy it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there everybody wants to go to heaven
but nobody wants to die